hello everyone in this video we're going
to be talking about models
no not that kind of model we're talking
about machine learning models and
specifically models that you or your
colleagues have built and are now
looking to deploy for your next change
the world application getting a model to
run on your laptop is great for
development and testing but what if you
need to run predictions against a large
batch of data or if you need to
continuously run predictions with a
model given a stream of ever arriving
data points robustly and at scale for
this you're going to need to make use of
a data processing framework one of my
favorites is Apache beam if you're new
to data engineering let's Zoom through
what you need to know about Apache beam
so what do you need to know Apache beam
has been around for a while it's
designed for data processing at scale
it's flexible and it's got plenty of
helpful utilities if you like choices
you'll be happy to know that it lets you
choose where to run it you can run it
on-prem or you can run it on the cloud
and it lets you pick your favorite among
several programming languages including
python Java and even go if you have a
data processing problem at scale there
is an excellent chance that Apache beam
is a great solution for you that said
Apache beam wasn't always the darling
that it is today back in the early days
the only supported language was Java and
we didn't have all the lovely helper
utilities for example the Run inference
utility that we'll talk about today
but technology is getting better and
better every day including the tools
that we use to build better Tech so if
you tried Apache beam in the old days
and you tossed it aside I'd encourage
you to give it another shot at winning
your affection
with all the progress It's hard to stay
on top of new developments some people
might simply not realize just how much
better this and other Solutions are
today at solving problems for you which
is why a lot of folks end up writing
dreams and reams of boilerplate code
themselves when you can achieve the same
goals in just a few lines of code
and that is what I'm here to tell you
however hard you think it is it's
probably not that hard
so let's take a look at the things that
you had to do before Apache beam
introduced The Run inference utility and
for this my friend Cassie will give
things a go hey Cassie I'm excited that
you want to find out what's in my code
so um let me take you through what I've
got going on here
first of all I have tens of thousands of
images in the cloud in this case they're
in a Google Cloud Storage bucket
so I'll need to get my pipeline to read
them and then get them in the right
shape for my model okay so Apache beam
will take care of making sure that all
the work gets spread across all the
machines that I've made available
okay next we'll transform these into the
right size for that I'll use a beam.map
function call okay that was the easy bit
okay so here's some fiddly setup I spent
several hours on this
this bit batches my values into a decent
size
I also need to load the model in but I
don't want to do that for every element
so let's just do it all in one go in the
do function this model is a big one with
lots of parameters so I better make sure
that it's shared across all the threads
we don't want to have lots of the same
model in memory
okay now this bit makes sure that the
data I want to predict has its metadata
attached
okay next we'll make the output a nice
stable object since I might want to use
this bit of code in several places let's
make sure that I copy all this
okay there we go
let me try to remember how do I make
sure that the model gets updated on the
Fly
okay okay stop that's all boilerplate
there is nothing specific to a model in
any of that stuff
okay Cassie I suppose I'll just have to
show us the right way to solve this
problem
we will use the Run inference transform
and pass in configuration information
about the model
in this case we're going to use the
image model from torch Vision which is
an open source model that I've
downloaded and put into the same bucket
location as my images
so let's just run this for a single
image and see the output
great done
and now we easily apply it to all of
them
and
we finished our job and now Cassie why
don't you take it from here and get that
data into a data warehouse well at least
now this bit's going to be the easy part
for me uh now I just need to make use of
beam.map again to run my post-processing
logic which is the same logic that I
used on my laptops I've just copy here
but now it's going to be done at scale
on all the images and then I'm gonna
push the results to my
database
thanks Cassie I think we've got it from
here so another advantage that we have
with Apache beam is that we can actually
make use of multiple models in the same
pipeline
let's have a look at some spaghetti I
mean complex multi-model pipeline I mean
spaghetti spaghetti really is the right
word for that mess my poor data point
will need to run a real obstacle course
to get through all this but luckily for
us
we don't have to code any obstacle
courses ourselves
if we ignore the details here what this
breaks down to is some simple patterns
that are just applied multiple times
from our data points point of view the
first pattern is a branch so our data
point has to go through two different
models at the same time the other
pattern is when a data point goes
through one model and then the result of
that transformation has to go into
another model let's see how this would
look in code for our branching problem
all we need to do is apply different
models to the same data the code for
this is very simple
and for our sequential models pattern
all we need to do is pass our data
through the first model after this we'll
normally need to shape the data for the
second model in the sequence which we'll
do with the beam.map function and that's
it we've rolled all that spaghetti into
some simple patterns
to the new run inference utility in
Apache beam running a model within a
pipeline is really easy with far less
boilerplate code less technical debt not
to mention less spaghetti and fewer
headaches we showed you how this works
with a large collection of data that was
in a storage bucket but with Apache beam
you can also easily work with data that
is coming from a streaming Source like
Apache Kafka or Google Cloud Pub sub all
you need to do is change the type of
reader
I encourage you to explore this topic
and get going with data engineering
machine learning and Apache Beam by
diving into the links you'll find in the
video description below
happy scaling
[Music]